How do microwaves cook your food?
If you stand in front of a microwave are you
going to get cancer?
Are they killing you?!
Howdy cookers, thanks for watching DNews,
I'm Trace.
This morning, I was talking to our intern
Tori // hello! // about how I microwaved coffee
from yesterday.
Yeah, I know, it's gross.
But it's SO EASY!
Microwaves are magic food boxes.
They heat food in less time with less energy
than traditional methods -- but HOW they make
that thing hotter is a mystery to many of
it's users...
The microwave has roots in radar research
during World War II.
Scientist Percy Spencer accidentally melted
a candybar in his pocket and after some more
experimentation, he patented[a] the first
microwave heating device!
Microwaves are basically metal boxes containing
a magnetron gun.
The magnetron uses electricity to excite electrons
and get them to vibrate and release waves
of non-ionized electromagnetic energy.
This radiation is at a frequency that's between
radio waves and infrared light -- usually
around 2.45 gigahertz.
This microwave "radiation" is no different
from the radiation created by a radio station
or a wifi-network.
The literal microwaves are made of alternating
current, and magnetic fields.
Because it's Alternating it means they're
switching from clockwise to counterclockwise
back and forth.
These electromagnetic waves shoot from the
magnetron into the oven passing through paper,
plastic, and glass to hit the water, fat and
sugar molecules in your cup of coffee or frozen
burrito.
Scientists aren't EXACTLY sure what happens
at this point.
Either the waves cause the H2O molecules to
agitate and generate heat, OR the fats, sugars
and water absorb the energy and release heat.
Either way, when the magnetron energy hits,
heat is created, and a minute or so later,
yesterday's coffee is as good as… well yesterday's
coffee.
Only hotter.
Because it's just heating water, fat and sugar
-- if it's not evenly distributed throughout
the burrito, it won't heat well!
Cold patch, yuck...
Also, setting it too hot too fast will only
mess up the process because the heat has to
travel into the food by conduction, that is,
one molecule spreads heat to the next and
then the next.
What a pain in the butt.
My mom used to tell me, "If you want children
someday don't stand too close to the microwave!"
Which isn't really true.
This microwave radiation isn't nearly as strong
an an x-ray, or as common as wifi, cell phone,
televisions or other electromagnetic waves
flying around.
Studies have found low-level microwave exposure
shouldn't cause the corruption of DNA that
results in cancer.
And looking into the microwave is fine, the
windows are shielded so microwaves are reflecting
onto the food, not into your sensitive little
eyeballs.
Metal in the microwave, isn't inherently bad,
either.
After all, the walls are made of it because
it reflects the waves all around, heating
as much of the food as possible.
However, throwing in something POINTY, like
aluminum foil, can cause sparks, and breakdown
of air molecules into more dangerous fumes.
The sleeves that come with some pastries are
also for reflection, because as the outside
of the food heats up, that heat energy is
reflected BACK at the crust, crisping it up.
It's cooking itself!
Whether microwaving is damaging the food is
still being debated by science, but for the
most part ANY cooking damages the nutrient
content of the "raw" food, but cooking it
also kills bacteria which makes food safer.
Yes, a few older studies found breast milk,
heated in a microwave, lost some of it's vitamin
B12 potency.
But many other studies have found no such
evidence.
And MANY studies done on microwaves have determined
there's little or no difference between microwaving
and conventional cooking.
Ultimately, the most dangerous things microwaves
produce are food burns from overheating the
item.
And that's just your fault.
The FDA says microwaving food is just as safe
and nutritious as any other method of cooking.
But what do you think?
Are you nervous about them?
Do you microwave your food?
Speak your mind down in the comments and be
sure you subscribe for more DNews.
Microwaves are also produced in space, and
on Wednesday, August 27 we're doing our next
monthly SpaceOut with NASA/JPL!
This month we're talking about Europa, the
possibility of life and future missions to
Jupiter's intriguing moon!
RSVP with the link here or in the description
and post a question so we can ask the experts!
Thanks for watching DNews.